dès que nous sommes se spécialise en
solutions de pompage industrielle depuis
plusieurs dollars comme se retrouve dans
un environnement min ça brise énormément
souvent mon mais les pompes mauvaises
perceptions sont probants nous font pas
la job c'est donc on on s'est dit il
faut que les foulées minhas minul le
pompage du goût ce cadre a toutefois eu
un éclair de génie qui allait changer
l'avenir à long terme de l'entreprise ou
une ronde yens tout le monde est capable
de mettre une passe et de chlore dans
une piscine pourquoi on ferait pas un
équipement géré la même idée ou le même
concept de mettre une percée dans un
panier et la logeuse pourrait se traiter
automatiquement
l'entreprise a ainsi mis au point une
partie entièrement organique qui
accélère la décantation
une fois la partie de polymères déposer
les effets sont pratiquement immédiat on
voit d'ailleurs la couleur de l'eau se
met à change nous les fait donc le rail
était faire passer de cette qualité
d'eau là à cette élite est double parce
que c'est théo l'eau est potable non
c'est pas ce qu'on recherche et nous
c'est un système tirs au but pour un à
lever la majeure partie des contamines à
la mode weezer d'été originellement
destinés à l'industrie minière
les mineurs n'ont pas nécessairement de
connaissances en génie des eaux ou en
environnement
le produit se devait donc d'être le plus
simple possible il faut pas commencer
assez d'ajuster des boutons partout il
faut être capable avec une simple
opération de mettre un panier comme sa
base dans un tuyau ça fonctionne technos
génère un chiffre d'affaires de près de
100 millions $ par année mais moins
d'oiseaux ne participe qu'à la hauteur
de 5 % des revenus totaux de
l'entreprise
jusqu'ici d'ici trois ans la direction
vu tripler ou quadrupler ce montant lors
faut que ça pas au sacré tescari parce
qu'on pense que ça peut faire très loin
à plus techno sommes avec son innovation
mode world a obtenu la reconnaissance de
la fondation cela impose ce fondation
s'est donné le défi de sélectionner 1000
éditions capable de protéger
l'environnement tout en demeurant
profitable des solutions qui peuvent
avoir un impact assez grand je peux me
changer beaucoup de chose sur la manière
de traitement de l'eau qui sont axées
sur la simplicité
donc ils vont bien aussi dans notre même
cette de rentabilité la gestion de mots
d'oiseaux l'a toujours été faite au
travers des activités quotidiennes des
quatre autres divisions de technophobes
mais en 2021
l'entreprise prévoit mettre sur pied une
toute nouvelle division exclusivement
consacré aux activités de mode world
au moins huit emplois seront créés ici
pierre côté radio canada à ronald à